hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
tochter
heute geht's endlich mal ein frühlings
rezept wir werden nämlich heute leckere
cupcakes machen mit einer frühlings oder
osterdeko und das sind leckere capex
denn da steckt noch ein bisschen möhren
mit drin samira zu mir hat sich die
haare heute ganz schön gemacht na ja
okay ich zeig euch da jetzt einfach mal
kurz die zutaten für den rührteig und
später zeige ich euch die zutaten für
die deko also wir brauchen hier 200
gramm zucker 70 gramm ölig messe ist
auch immer gerne in öl ab denn dann kann
ich einfach die schlüssel auf die waage
stellen und dann habe ich das eben das
ist neutrales sonnenblumenöl ein
teelöffel backpulver partie 80 gramm
koks raste ihr könnt gerne auch andere
nüsse nehmen
und ich habe hier 125 gramm mehl und
dann brauche ich noch ein paar karotten
und zwar 100 km kleider kasper so wir
stellen jetzt hier kurz den teig her und
ich mach das jetzt in der küchenmaschine
aber ihr könnt auch mit einem trend
zurück gerät machen einfach rein und ich
hole gleich nochmal ein vanille extrakt
denn es geht auch noch mit rein aber nie
vergessen herauszustellen jetzt der
zucker mit rein zu den eiern
ja das macht nichts jetzt wird es
verheerend so etwa 34 minuten lang bis
schön weiß cremig ist
in der zwischenzeit raspel ich schon
meine karotten das mache ich jetzt in
der küchenmaschine
aber wer so ein gerät hat kann das auch
damit machen
ich nehme ich meinen vanille extrakt und
gibt das jetzt mit hier dazu einfach so
ein paar tropfen
wenn ihr das nicht können auch
vanillezucker nehmen aber hier ist
einfach das aroma intensiver und kommt
noch das öl mit rein
das darfst du machen wir uns zusammen
das rühre ich kurz bei niedriger stufe 1
niedrig heißt langsam und jetzt wäre ich
hier backpulver mittelmeer
der papa mit anfragen ich gemacht ja das
kurz berührt und ich gebe schon mal die
kokosraspeln hier mit dazu das reicht
schon jetzt ist da rein machen und jetzt
geben wir noch die karotten mit dazu
also 150 gramm
und dann wird es einfach nicht schnell
verrührt natürlich
sieht lecker aus
und ein recht verrückt einfach hier so
ein bisschen teigs aber ich will nämlich
nicht zu lange rühren aber soeben dass
ich alles verbindet genau die kann schon
mal anziehen
ich habe hier bereits meinen muffin
backblech mit weißem papier folie
ausgekleidet und werde jetzt einfach
darin baku und dafür nämlich nun als
portionierer und gebt den tag hinein
das kommt beim später ging und später
habe ich dann andere papier förmchen mit
so einem muster trautmann im design
drauf und die werde ich doch einfach da
reinstecken dann fetten die nämlich auch
nicht so durch und das muss schon
richtig schön erkennbar
und jetzt gehen die muffins 3 175 grad
ober und unterhitze für ungefähr 25
minuten in den backofen
es kann auch sein dass es schon nach 20
minuten fertig sind kommt einfach auf
eurem backofen drauf an
die stäbchen problem zahnstocher dürfte
nicht vergessen danach lasse ich sie
abkühlen und in der zwischenzeit
bereitet gleich schon mal die deko vor
also ich bereite jetzt schon mal alles
vor wenn die muffins gleichzeitig sind
dass wir dann sofort beider dekorieren
können sobald sie kalt sind und jetzt
hier einfach so martin oster set und
zwar sind da um star muffin förmchen und
aber auch finanzieren also dass ihm
diese filmchen mit drin die ich jetzt
gleich noch benutzt man kann darin auch
packen aber ich finde es immer besser
wenn man in weiß verpackt und die dann
nimmt damit es einfach bisschen hübscher
aussieht dann sind das osterhäschen drin
gemeinsam ihre und inter streuseln die
benutzten wir gleich für die deko aber
ich möchte noch ein bisschen was selber
dazu modellieren und deswegen nehme ich
mir jetzt heute hier modelle schokolade
darf ich jetzt einfach verschiedene
farben hingelegt in blau weiß grün rot
und rosa und ich brauche ein bisschen
gelb deswegen habe ich werden von doping
und jetzt bei diesem paar karotten
modellieren und zeigt euch einfach mal
wie man es ganz schnell selber macht
kann man kann die zwar auch schon fertig
kaufen
die kennt wahrscheinlich auch jeder so
diese ganz harten zucker bonbons aber
ich finde wenn man sehr aus modelle
schokolade macht am streckenverlauf muss
halt auch echt gut essen
jetzt möchte ich hier gelben von der mit
roter moderne schokolade damit ich
einfach ein schönes orange erhalten und
dann brauche ich auch keinen cmc pulver
damit davon dorffest er irrt denn die
modelle schokolade wird ja wenn es
wieder kalt wird also die stadt kalten
zustand ist und da muss ich sie weicht
nähten mit seiner körperwärme und damit
eben auch wieder versteht ihn gemacht
jetzt konnte ich es einfach mit den
fingern weich und mich dann immer wieder
von dem geld dazu
hab ich das schöne orange und jetzt
werde ich daraus sechs karotten formen
und ihr könnt einfach selber bestimmen
wie groß gemacht ich nehme jetzt einfach
mal so was großes stück nicht wahrnimmst
große etwa zwei zentimeter
und die wollte ich mir jetzt zur kugel
und die reststoffe war ich einfach hier
in so einer kleinen superform auch
einfach damit sie nicht austrocknen und
jetzt nehme ich mir so eine kugel und
form sie etwas lang
so hat eine richtig schöne möhre werden
also vorne etwas dicker und hinten etwas
dünner
und daneben durch irgend einem werkzeug
zum beispiel messer ich habe es hier
einst aus kunststoff und dann fahr mich
hier einfach so ein paar striche rein
also sowieso dieses karotten musste
wobei echte kaputten eigentlich nicht so
aussehen aber irgendwie macht mir das
alte
mit sich die hier kurz ausruhen und
knete meine grüne modelliermasse weiß
jetzt nehmt ihr euch da immer so ganz
kleines stückchen und formen zu lang zu
einer rolle die vorne also in der mitte
tätig sein und hinten an den enden etwas
dünner und das wird dann später einfach
dieses grünzeug bei der karotte hin
und jetzt müsste einfach nur noch hinten
so ein kleines loch reinmachen das mache
ich es auch mit so einem whirlpool also
mit seinem kugel wahlberg zeit könnt
aber auch zum beispiel die rückseite von
einem löffel oder irgendwas anderes
nehmen im cache pop stil einfach damit
das grünzeug treiben kann
das mache ich jetzt nämlich so da lege
ich zwei übereinander anziehen oder
kreuzt und biegt dann hoch und das wird
dann einfach hinten reingedrückt und zum
fixieren können das mit so einem anderen
model ihr werkzeug kinder nachhilfe oder
eben was anderes spitze und wenn man das
sofort ist das schöne macht dann hat man
eine hübsche karotte ich mache jetzt
einfach hier noch mal fährt und dann
bereite ich gleich schon unser topping
zu und dann sind wir auch gleich schon
fertig
meine machen sind jetzt komplett
abgekühlt meine karotten linken hielt
auch schon seit etwa zwanzig minuten
herum und jetzt kann ich meinen frosting
vorbereiten und einfach die cupcakes
fertigte problem für das frosting habe
ich hier bereits drei zutaten oder 4
ich habe 100 gramm butter 100 g
frischkäse und 100 gramm puderzucker und
ich nehme auch ein bisschen von der
vanille einfach für den geschmack das
kommt jetzt einfach alles in eine kleine
schüssel wobei ich zuerst jetzt mutter
mit puderzucker kurz verlöre damit sich
der puderzucker bisserl auflösen kann
und dann kommt noch der frischkäse dazu
nicht fertig so dass kurz miteinander
verrühren
am besten niedriger stufe
jetzt kannst du das kurz festhalten
jetzt kommt ein bisschen vanille mit
dazu auch wieder nur ein paar tropfen
und dann der frischkäse und sobald der
frischkäse dabei ist holen wir nur noch
ganz kurz bis es sich vermischt hat
damit einfach nicht flüssig wird an der
stelle gebe ich jetzt noch ein bisschen
grüne lebensmittelfarbe mit dazu finde
ich möchte gleich dass es aussieht wie
ein bisschen gras als devise
deswegen hoffe ich hier einfach bisschen
lebensmittel pasta rhein könnte in jedem
supermarkt bekommen übrig und flüssige
farben würde ich jetzt annehmen so ein
schweres ding einfach zu flüssig
ich nehme es noch ein bisschen geld
damit ich ein schönes hellgrün erhalten
und jetzt nehme ich mir einfach einen
einblick spritzbeutel und gebt dass eine
glastür ein und zwar seht ihr bei mir so
aus die hat vorne ganz viele kleine
löcher und mit der kann ich dann so eine
farce optik erzählen will ich hier ganz
kurz ein
jetzt setze ich meine abgekühlten
muffins eben meine hübschen muffin
förmchen danke samira genau macht das
einfach mal weiter und ich kann schon
mal das gras auf spritzen
jetzt kann ich einfach die deko noch
draufsetzen
so wie hier so ein märchen mitten ins
gras und dann nehme ich mir so einen
hasen stecker und steckt den mit dazu
dann haben wir ziemlich schnell
dekoriert
und was wir auch machen könnte es gibt
nämlich so es mache schmetterlinge die
mache ich da jetzt nämlich auch mit
drauf weil ich finde schmetterlinge
passen richtig schön auf so eine
frühlingswiese und die sind hier in so
einer folie und die sind bereits vor
gestand das heißt ich kann sie hier
einfach mit den fingern ein bisschen
raus trennen
metro sei auch ein amt
und dann kann man die nämlich noch
umknicken
so hatte ich mache jeder trick
schleifmittel gras und wenn man die so
ein bisschen wie kann man sie nämlich
somit draufsetzen
zu sehen jetzt dekorierten cupcakes aus
und ich möchte euch aber auch mal von
innen zeigen
aber da ich nicht gern vor der kamera es
guckt ihr euch jetzt die an und presst
rein und dann besteht cupcake richtig
schöner saftiger cupcake der schmeckt so
ein bisschen nach kokos die karotten
schmeckt man eigentlich nie raus
deswegen fehlschüssen rezept falls ihr
mal ausprobieren sollten gerne dürfte es
auch abwandeln und mir dann eure
kommentare unter mein video schreiben
wie ihr es findet was ihr noch für deko
ideen habt und das rezept gibt es auf
ganz genau und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder bis bald steiner